how's everybody doing today you may have
noticed quite a few new players hopping
in a fortnight lately maybe even people
haven't played a lot of video games
we're gonna talk about six common
mistakes that players make in the game
and how to get a little bit better
let's talk games number one not mapping
building to hotkeys the default controls
in fortnight are way too slow and will
likely get you killed you should have at
least walls and ramps map when combined
they make the fastest for it's never
just build one layer of walls have
fallback walls just in case because
other teams will shoot them about as
fast as you can put them up while you're
at it map your first weapon slot to an
easy to reach mouse button or heat you
never want to die with your pickaxe out
that's kind of embarrassing as you run
across the map practice switching
between weapons and building to get
those hotkeys in your muscle memory
number two forgetting to build under
fire it's easy to panic when the Rockets
start flying but taking a second to set
yourself up with a couple of walls can
make a huge difference wood starts with
more initial hit points and can take
more hits while being constructed brick
and steel have higher max hit points and
can take a lot more punishment when
completed when enemy teams try and ramp
up and over your forts build ramps to
the same plane height as them in order
to engage or if you're fast enough shoot
out the base of their ramp to make the
whole thing collapse most importantly
make sure to harvest enough resources at
the start of a round if you get to the
end circles and can't put up walls or
ramps you're probably a goner
number three
forgetting to knock down enemy forts
chop down enemy forts as they're built
preferably at the base to bleed enemy
teams resources and open them up if you
do manage to chop out the base of a
tower the entire thing will fall don't
expect anything you hide behind a hold
though almost all objects can be
destroyed number four landing in hot
spots if you want to go to tilted towers
to learn how to fight that's one thing
but if you're playing to make it to the
late-game this might be a bad idea
Landing areas that are rich in loot and
aren't as likely to see fights early on
such as shifty shafts or moisty mire no
promises though also don't land on a
house second if someone beats you to the
ground definitely move somewhere else in
town so you have plenty of room to get
arms winning a pickaxe fight is dicey at
best assuming one of you doesn't have a
weapon number five
forgetting to share health items
scattered around the map our blue shield
potions and bandages you should drink
shield oceans right away to build up a
second layer of shields but anything
extra that you find you should give to a
friend you can actually drop or simply
divide out shields and bandages from
your inventory menu if your team goes
down you're a lot more likely to lose
anyway so there's little reason to horde
what you find number six
picking the wrong weapon don't let the
cartoonish style fool you treat every
gunfight in this game like it's your
last you don't need to hold back because
if you win you should have plenty of
weapons to scavenge anyway remember when
picking up items not all weapons in
fortnight are created equal there are
color variations from gray to gold that
indicate their power so for example
ditch green for blue blue for purple
purple for orange and so on make sure
you understand the ideal range of
weapons don't shoot the wrong gun at the
wrong range or you'll just let people
know you're there but also keep in mind
that shotguns have more range than you
think and are some of the most powerful
weapons in the game some guns look great
like the new minigun and they are great
at chopping down forts but are pretty
lousy at killing players overall just
make sure you practice enough to know
what guns are good with
alright those are some of the most
common mistakes we've seen new players
making in fortnight what about you tell
us some of the things you see new
players doing what are your favorite
landing zones let's talk about it in the
comments below thanks for watching